um it it almost feels surreal that i am
telling you this today because i think
many of us
at least would like to believe that this
is not the type of thing that would be
possible in the united states but it is
possible we would be naive to think it's
not possible
and that's why the fbi has started
vetting the national guard troops who
are in washington dc
to protect the city to protect the
capital to protect the white house
in advance of enduring joe biden's
inauguration and the reason the fbi is
vetting national guard troops
is that there are fear of insider trump
loyalists
who may even assist in or participate
in an attack tomorrow inauguration day
uh i'm almost at a loss for words
but this should not come as a total
surprise because two weeks ago i told
you
that uh joe biden's entire secret
service team
is being replaced rather than the
typical some trump secret service people
carry over
and some people retire and then they
bring in some new people which would be
the standard thing because of concerns
about
trump loyalists in secret service joe
biden
is getting an all-new team including
some agents from the obama era that
worked with biden
in his capacity as vice president as
well as new agents not believed to be
trump loyalists so we knew that a couple
of weeks ago
and now as you know because of the trump
riots on january 6th
national guard troops have been called
to washington d.c and they've been
patrolling the streets and street
corners of washington d.c for a week now
if you look at images of it it looks
dystopian
it looks like things we would imagine
only happen in other countries but
they're happening right here in the
united states
but it is not quite so simple defense
officials
and the fbi are worried about an insider
attack
or threat from these very service
members involved in securing
joe biden's inauguration and this has
led the fbi
to start vetting all 25 000 national
guard troops
coming to washington dc or already in
washington dc for this event
now imagine what it takes to vet 25
000 troops to figure out might this be a
trump loyalist has this person been
visiting certain websites on the
internet
coordinating with certain people on the
internet and unfortunately
that degree of vetting is not going to
be possible uh what it is what it is
going to include
uh is some more automated processes for
looking through
folks maybe more detailed looks at
people from certain areas or people
um with certain characteristics i don't
even know how you'd vet 25
000 people and they're expected to be
doing the vetting all the way
up to tomorrow's inauguration and this
is a situation where
i mean listen the fbi will run
everybody's names through databases
they'll see if any of the names appear
on watch lists already maintained
to see if there's something alarming
that comes up um
if there have been names of the troops
that have been associated with prior
investigations
or terrorism related concerns but the
deep vetting that would be done like for
example for people who will be
close to joe biden in a secret service
capacity you just can't do that with 25
000 national guard troops
uh coming to washington dc on relatively
short notice but the fact that this is
even being done
is of course horrifying and very very
scary
and i i hate to say this i don't want to
make this all negative
because we are removing trump that's a
good thing and hopefully getting a fresh
start on a lot of these issues that that
we failed on as a country over the last
four years
but this is an issue radicalization of
law enforcement and military
that's been studied for a long time the
brennan center for justice has a report
called hidden in plain sight
racism white supremacy and far-right
militancy
in law enforcement now we've known for a
long time that law enforcement
tends to be more conservative than the
population at large
law enforcement tends to vote quite a
bit more for republicans rather than
democrats
the military is not historically made up
of at the sort of lower levels
uh particularly progressive individuals
although in 2020 joe biden did see more
support from within the military
than democratic presidents have seen for
a long time but this
issue of militancy and white supremacy
and racism within law enforcement
has been studied for a long time by the
brennan center for justice
and it is important to understand that
it is a widely known
issue and that while of course
mo i've said before this is not an
anti-cop
show or an anti-military show in terms
of the individuals
i continue to believe and this is based
on both everything i've read
empirically and my personal experience
most police officers become police
officers for the right reasons
most people who join the military join
the military not
to go out and kill people in cold blood
or
or they they do join for what they see
as
doing something good for their community
or their country the unfortunate reality
is that law enforcement and the military
also attract
uh disproportionately culturally
conservative people
disproportionately folks motivated more
by fear and and possibly anger
disproportionately more people to
and i hate to say it um be sympathetic
to the ideas of far-right militancy now
that doesn't mean that
it's the majority it's not but relative
to the population
they are over-represented and so that's
something that has to be dealt with
law enforcement and and the military
have have tried different ideas
uh and so far it has not worked
particularly well and it remains a
quote persistent threat according to the
fbi
um so the the point here is it shouldn't
be a surprise
that this is a concern even including
the national guard troops that will be
supposedly securing washington d.c for
the inauguration of joe biden
i'm hopeful but unsure if this
late-stage vetting that the fbi
is doing will be enough but my hope is
that even if some individuals slip
through
who are sympathetic to some of the goals
of the rioters
and would-be rioters that they will be
so few and far between
among the 25 000 national guard troops
that it will not really lead to an
opportunity for anybody to do anything
that even resembles what we saw on
january 6th
that's my hope and i hope it doesn't end
up being
a naive hope but we will be watching it
as we will
be covering joe biden's inauguration
tomorrow and i hope you will join me we
will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook
starting at 11 a.m eastern time 8 a.m
pacific time we will start an hour
before we will see the gathering in
washington d.c
the swearing-in of joe biden as
president the swearing-in of kamala
harris's vice president
and then we will have a a a changing of
the guard we will officially have it
trump will be out
biden will be in and we will go right
into
demanding that joe biden do the things
he promised to do on day one i'll give
him until day two i'll be honest i'll i
think
day literally day one is tough but
maybe the first full day i expect
executive orders from joe biden
on thursday and we will be here with you
for everything so
we'll see you for that tomorrow we have
a great show today let me know if you'll
be watching i'm on twitter at dpakman
if one of your goals for the new year is
to cut back on carbs and sugar
check out one of our sponsors monk pack
monk pack keto granola bars fill you up
and taste like your favorite sweet
snacks
but they just have one gram of sugar
just two grams of net carbs at only 140
calories they have a soft
chewy texture and they come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip
peanut butter and maple pecan
or pecan or pecan it's all of the above
actually
they're perfect for a quick breakfast a
snack between
zoom calls or a late night treat not
only are they keto friendly they're
gluten-free
grain-free plant-based no soy trans fats
or sugar alcohols no artificial colors
and monk pack is so confident in their
keto snacks
that they back them with a hundred
percent money back guarantee
try it for yourself and you'll see how
delicious these are
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to monkpack.com and use coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video